lancé en octobre dernier le plan vélo de
la ville de tours vient de se terminer
bilan positif
au delà des attentes la ville a
d'ailleurs dû multiplier l'enveloppent
des aides par six au total près de 2500
vélos ont été achetés en trois mois
les explications de samuel colin entre
le 12 octobre et le 31 décembre 1464
vélos sont achetés dans la ville de
tours
la subvention de la municipalité pour
chaque achat est en moyenne de 193 euros
à l'heure du bilan le budget
prévisionnel de 50000 euros est
largement dépassé 318 1582 euro sont
finalement consacré à cette mesure d'
aide à l'obtention d'un vélo dans le
cadre de trajets quotidiens
les élus qu'on ne finançait la
différence avec le budget des
investissements non réalisés en 2020 du
fait de la crise sanitaire
il y avait une partie déjà quittées sur
le musée de l'année dernière cent mille
été mis dans le programme du complément
on va le faire cette année soit 10 à une
expérimentation par définition il ya des
surprises
c'est une bonne surprise pour autant
seuls 65% des nouveaux propriétaires ont
aujourd'hui leur vélo dans les mains car
tous les vélocistes connaissent des
ruptures de stock des modèles
indisponible à cause là encore de la
pandémie
elle crie à la fois des tensions dans
l'approvisionnement et la fabrication de
pièces et une explosion de la demande
mondiale l'activité des professionnels
tourangeau est d'ailleurs continue
depuis le printemps
et cette subvention de la ville a
accentué la tendance
on n'a pas pu répondre à toute la
demande qu on en a loupé mais alors que
je pense que c'est le plus frustrant
c'est cela et l'autre voyage on est pas
trop mal tiré
les vélos de ville on a été très vite en
rupture aussi les vélos de ville on n'a
jamais trop de protéines beaucoup de
demandes de vélos de ville nomme
électrique mais on s'en est sortis pas
trop mal exemple de délais d'attentes
six mois juillet prochain pour obtenir
un modèle précis les vélos subventionnés
sont à 80% mécanique et 20 % électrique